et dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
le gouvernement s'est réuni en séminaire
hier soir pour faire un bilan de son
action à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles oui comment relancer les
réformes dans ce contexte de crise et l
objet de cette réunion inédite
bruno le maire lui c'est justement
exprimé en début de semaine sur ses
grandes priorités afin de mener râle
bien je cite l'ambition réformatrice du
chef de l'état une déclaration qui nous
allons le voir a fait réagir notre
éditorialiste vu que la vida l'on
n'écoute bruno le maire et on en parle
après remplacer mois dorures et que vos
bureaux sont compliquées que pour
retrouver un conseiller il faut arpenter
quatre couloirs tourné cinq portes toute
décorée avec des stucs que je ne pense
pas que ça favorise un travail efficace
cher nicolas bonjour alors cette
déclaration de bruno le maire elle vous
a étonné en sourit encore là je le
revois cette déclaration de bruno le
maire effectivement chez france inter
bon rapidement bruno le maire c'est le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance économique rappelez-vous
ça fait rappeler arnould bourrin le
relance économique déjà s'il veut
quinquennat avant bruno le maire il est
normalien il est énarque il est des
piles étaient députés et les ministres
multicartes ministre de la culture en
2009 est maintenant ministre de
l'économie et des finances vous savez
bout de nerfs aussi c'est le ministre
qui suture qui suggérait qui implore la
limitation des plans sociaux mais on a
eu bridgestone en à air france on a
d'ailleurs en aéroports de paris renaud
auchan et voilà des plans sociaux en
veux tu en voilà finalement vous ne le
maire c'est l'action publique de
l'impuissance
avec cette vague de licenciements sur
cette déclaration
n'oublions pas à bruno le maire est en
train de sortir un bouquin en ce moment
voilà donc il est ou peu en promo et
puis bruno le maire c'est un petit
coquin parce que bruno le maire j'ai
fait ma revue de presse d'hier et il
avait la vue des coûts pardon en 2015 au
parisien fait un shaker chazal il a le
journal il avait exactement parler de la
monarchie technocratique donc on va dire
que c'est un peu du micro ondable
resucée pour vous ne le maire mais
peut-être qu'il est dans déjà l'esprit
de l'incantation de 2022
le maire et qui nous fait preuve de
persuasion là dessus mais cette
dénonciation de cette monarchie
technocratique vous parait-elle tout de
même valable à nicolas oui alors vous ne
le mérite ou fait le coup on peut la
réhabilitation de la cause du peuple
c'est à dire la fracture entre les
élites d'assez sécher entre les élites
et le peuple
mais ce qui est génial si bruno le maire
sait qui nous donne la définition
parfaite de ce que j'appelle ce que
plusieurs appellent la poste démocratie
vous savez là magali cette idéologie
finalement qui voudrait protéger le
peuple de lui même de son immaturité par
une élite éclairée qui finalement vu
vote sa souveraineté avec cette
mesquinerie démocratique une citation il
part de leurs cours la course et
l'estrie français depuis 1789 la course
et pas plus trop à la mode un pour bruno
le maire bien entendu et là on est
vraiment sur quelque chose qui est assez
savoureux dans cette déclaration
notamment quand on se serre emmanuel
macron on a quand même l'impression que
c'est un peu c'est un peu incroyable
voilà et puis après donc bien c'était
une technocratie vous monarchique et
puis après aussi il faut noter il ya la
dénonciation du conseil constitutionnel
notamment avec la présence de laurent
fabius et d'alain juppé et son rôle
politique dans la démocratie ça c'est
assez étonnant
voilà pour au ministre en exercice et
donc ils toujours il peut pas oublier
qu'il est en promotion ne le maire par
rapport à ça et puisqu'il se pose comme
question fondamentale sur ce genre de
déclarations c'est la question je lui
dis chaque fois c'est la question du
patriotisme de la technocratie
finalement la question du patriotisme
des élites qu'elle soit européenne ou
française et bruno le maire donc des
dons dégage finalement à une certaine
forme de démocratie par le rapprochement
et le peuple les intérêts du peuple
mais cette question aujourd'hui et
centra de l'action publique encore plus
dense et un trouble pour notre pays
nicolas vous ne portez donc pas de
crédit à bruno le maire ben pas du tout
20 non malheureusement non parce que
grosso modo la meilleure qui change les
10000 fois sur ce plateau la meilleure
question si on voulait vraiment passer
aux actes c'est la mise en place de
référendum pour être plus proche des
citoyens bruno le maire nous lier un
système plus simple plus efficace et
plus proche des citoyens
mais j'ai la réponse au bout de lemaire
ce sont les référendums directes sur les
questions centrales c'est le moins pour
moi c'est le vaccin finalement contre la
défaillance
le naufrage l'élite et contre la perte
de légitimité la parole publique et ça
ça s'appelle la démocratie directe
suffrage universel ça existe déjà et
vous savez le général de gaulle dit
souvent la cour suprême en france c'est
le peuple
voilà pour bruno le maire quelques
pistes de réflexion qui pourrait
prolonger sa réflexion sur ce livre
langer la bête qui est sorti cette
semaine
voilà un peu ce que je dis et puis une
dernière chose bruno le maire finalement
vous savez c'est celui qui a fait le
bercy lab à bercy pour se rencontrer
échanger sa j'adore
et puis c'est aussi les 42 42 kilomètres
de couloirs à bercy où bruce est à
toutes les clés des portes et finalement
cette entremise avec l'union européenne
je le dis en permanence on ne peut pas
accéder à la souveraineté pages du
populaire
si on répond diktat de bruxelles en
permanence voilà donc on est toujours
aussi entre la souveraineté nationale et
la souveraineté populaire
aujourd'hui on a délégué le tout brent
et à bruxelles il n'y a plus de
souveraineté populaire car la
représentation nationale finalement
députés et sénateurs votent pratiquement
80% des lois qui émane de bruxelles dont
dans ce cas là il faudrait un grand
changement
là dessus donc c'est pour ça que pour
répondre à votre question que je n'y
crois pas tellement aux déclarations de
bruno le maire nicolas vidal un dernier
mot il nous reste un petit peu de temps
bruno le maire qui a du mal à travailler
dans les dorures le gouvernement lui qui
s'est réuni et c'est assez inédit on
séminaire hier pour faire le point et il
jure que ce n'est pas du tout en vue des
élections présidentielles vous y croyez
le gouvernement se réunit en séminaire
je l' ai vu ce 13 janvier bien entendu
alors ce matin dès potron minet je peux
analyser
qu'est ce qui sort de sa belle histoire
la réforme des retraites et il sort la
réforme de l'assurance chômage donc
emmanuel macron il veut absolument faire
passer ses réformes là je le répète en
permanence il ya eu un deal avec le pact
le plan de relance européen signé cet
été avec bruxelles et c'est dans le deal
on vous donne de l'argent si vous mettez
en place ces réformes néolibérales qui
déstructure l'état je vais pas remparts
et des masques que je vais pas en parler
de la preuve de stratégie de vaccination
mais le séminaire glande gouvernemental
c'est pour savoir quand est ce on met en
place la réforme des retraites et la
réforme doit que ce chômage
voilà ce qui est en train d'être mis en
place pour emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron il veut qu'on comptait
comptabilisé calculer la marge de
manoeuvre qui lui restent calmes
22 mais très sincèrement ça va être très
très court parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
se dépêtrer cette crise sanitaire et je
pense comme on dit chez moi qui les 13
ans keane emmanuel mâcon gras par la
crise sanitaire
finalement pas que l'on pense merci
beaucoup nicolas vidal on vous retrouve
jeudi prochain pour un nouvel édito dans
la matinale de rtl france